[Aplausos]
[Música]
Corea del Sur años 50 después de más de
tres décadas de colonización japonesa de
la división del país en dos y de tres
años de guerra fratricida el país estaba
destrozado para colmo casi toda la
industria la minería y el 80% de la
producción eléctrica que existían cuando
Corea se partió en dos en 1948 se
concentraban en la parte Norte Corea del
Sur nació siendo extremadamente pobre
los años 50 supercapita era inferior al
de países como Haití Etiopía o yemen
el primer presidente surcoreano sigman
reel lideró algunas reformas como la
agraria o la creación de un sistema
educativo de relativamente alta calidad
Pero eso no era suficiente la economía
surcoreana dependía básicamente de una
agricultura rudimentaria y de la ayuda
internacional de socios como los Estados
Unidos sin embargo un momento porque de
repente eso empezó a cambiar en cuestión
de muy pocas décadas Corea del Sur sería
un país completamente diferente
[Música]
Esto es algo de lo que ya os hemos
hablado en pasados vídeos de
visualpolitik Corea del Sur es hoy en
día uno de los países más ricos y
avanzados tecnológicamente de todo el
planeta tierra hablamos de un líder
industrial de primer nivel y todos
conocéis marcas como Samsung o Hyundai
pero es que la economía surcoreana llega
a muchísimos más sitios no importa si
hablamos de acero coches o incluso
barcos Corea es incluso una potencia en
semiconductores que como ya sabéis es el
petróleo del siglo XXI las empresas
coreanas son capaces de fabricar
semiconductores tan avanzados que ni
siquiera los Estados Unidos pueden hacer
algo igual y todo eso por no hablar de
los rascacielos el k-pop o hasta las
series de Netflix Y sí tal y como
seguramente muchos estaréis imaginando
Esta es una de esas historias que tienen
un personaje principal un protagonista
una figura absolutamente clave
en 1961 la situación económica de Corea
del Sur seguía sin mejorar demasiado y
la corrupción y el descontento social
crecían como la espuma al final toda
esta irritación social terminó
explotando con un golpe de estado
militar que en ese momento muchos
apoyaron porque pensaban que si se
lograría algo de estabilidad de esta
forma el general parche y derrocó el
gobierno del recién electo Primer
Ministro chamnio instauró Un gobierno
militar reformista dirigido por el mismo
parche se convirtió en presidente
todopoderoso en 1962 su larga dictadura
duraría 18 años
y ojo porque cuando hablamos de gobierno
militar reformista nos referimos a que
esta dictadura tenía una obsesión por
encima de cualquier otra y no no
hablamos de gasto militar sino de
Industria industria y más industria Park
estaba convencido de que solo así el
país podría escapar de la pobreza pero
para conseguirlo hacía falta un plan
queréis saber qué fue lo que hizo hasta
qué punto se lograron cambiar las cosas
radicalmente en Corea del Sur es Acaso
este el mejor modelo posible para países
que quieren escapar de la pobreza hoy en
día hoy vamos a responder a estas
preguntas pero antes antes un apunte
importante si estoy buscando contenido
diferente aquí en YouTube quedados hasta
el final del vídeo porque tenemos una
recomendación muy pero que muy especial
de nuestros amigos de Planet Wild que
realizan proyectos para cambiar el mundo
a mejor y no os lo podéis perder Y ahora
vamos a ver un poco de historia
[Música]
el nacimiento de una estrella industrial
hace algunos años en un pasado vídeo
aquí en visualpolitik ya os dimos
algunas pinceladas sobre el desarrollo
de Corea del Sur un modelo que no tiene
nada que ver con las típicas recetas de
Libre Mercado inversión extranjera y
bajos impuestos de las que normalmente
os solemos hablar en este canal en Corea
del Sur durante un tiempo las cosas se
hicieron de una forma un poquito
diferente Ahora bien la pregunta que
todos estáis esperando es Pero qué
hicieron exactamente Pues bien según la
mayoría de los analistas podemos
identificar al menos tres fases
la primera fase fue la que corresponde a
la política de sustitución de
importaciones esta política fue la
impulsada por el presidente Rey desde
que terminó la guerra de Corea en 1953
hasta la llegada al poder de Park en
1961 básicamente consistía en tratar de
impulsar la economía sustituyendo
productos importados por otros hechos en
Corea del Sur no funcionó la segunda
fase fue la de la industrialización
orientada a las exportaciones o la del
estado desarrollista y fue la que se
llevó a cabo durante la dictadura de
Park Y por último estaría la fase del
equilibrio y la estabilización que se
considera que comenzó los años 80 y que
llega hasta el periodo actual en esta
fase se abrió el mercado surcoreano con
una liberalización progresiva y se
fomentó la inversión extranjera directa
y ya sé lo que estaréis pasando todos en
este momento he estado desarrollista
Pero qué demonios es eso del estado de
desarrollista
Pues veréis un estado desarrollista es
un sistema político y económico bastante
común entre los países emergentes de
Asia y África básicamente consiste en
intentar promover el desarrollo
económico a través de la
industrialización os acordáis de que
decíamos que este general está
posicionado que en industria industria y
más industria Pues eso pero claro hablar
de industrialización es muy fácil es
como si yo digo que de repente me
gustaría ser ingeniero cuántico lo
difícil por supuesto es lograrlo Así que
la pregunta es qué demonios hicieron los
surcoreanos Pues bien básicamente dopar
la industria cebarla todo lo posible y
más mientras al mismo tiempo se
restringían las importaciones para el
régimen de Park sounji todo lo demás
daba absolutamente igual ni bienestar
social ni subsidios a la gente ni nada
por el estilo prácticamente todos los
recursos disponibles se dirigieron a la
industria el estado apoyaba que las
empresas crecieran Y a cambio estas
tenían que invertir y exportar todo lo
que pudieran la idea era que con todos
estos gigantes nacionales y una
industria desarrollada la riqueza
terminaría inundando a todos los
estratos de la sociedad ahora bien Esto
suena muy bonito y en principio parece
que es muy fácil verdad sin embargo
recordad que os hemos dicho que Corea
del Sur partía de una situación
miserable pero mi Sara vale De verdad la
guerra de Corea dejó el país hundido y
eran extremadamente pobres y de verdad
hablamos de pobreza real uno de los
países más pobres de toda Asia Entonces
como diantres se podía impulsar la
industria con semejante panorama
[Música]
Pues veréis aquí estuvo una de las
jugadas clave para conseguir el dinero
lo primero que hizo el régimen del
General Park fue idear un sistema en el
que era el estado quien buscaba la
financiación por todo el mundo y luego
se la entregaba a las empresas con
préstamos artificialmente baratos de
esta forma el gobierno surcoreano solo
cargaba con el coste de los intereses al
mismo tiempo que se aseguraba de que las
empresas surcoreanas tuvieran todo el
dinero que necesitaban para crecer lo
más rápido posible esta financiación
viene fundamentalmente de dos lugares
Estados Unidos y Japón pero queréis un
dato pues veréis tan solo en la década
que transcurre entre los años 1972 y
1982 la deuda externa creció en términos
absolutos un
825%, pasó de 4.000 millones de dólares
a más de 37.000 Claro que como la
industria ya estaba comenzando a
exportar y El despegue económico estaba
comenzando gracias a ello los pagos de
la deuda en relación a la riqueza del
país apenas crecieron Aunque eso sí no
todo el dinero se consigue con préstamos
también hubo partes que se consiguieron
a través de la diplomacia
concretamente en el año 65 el presidente
Park negoció y firmó el tratado de
relaciones básicas entre Japón y la
República de Corea gracias a este
tratado el país del anime el Sushi y el
origami Le entregó a Corea del Sur 800
millones de dólares dólares de la época
en forma de subvenciones y préstamos a
bajos intereses y diréis pero Eso era
mucho o poco dinero pues atentos esos
800 millones de dólares equivalían a más
del 20% de todo el pib surcoreano de
aquí al año y la pregunta es qué pensáis
que hizo el Gobierno surcoreano con todo
ese dinero pues hizo Exactamente lo
mismo que hizo con el dinero que pedía
prestado en el mercado internacional es
decir entregar solo a las empresas para
que estas construyeran la industria
nacional
Para repartir el dinero el gobierno
confió sobre todo en un grupo de
familias de empresarios que ya habían
hecho negocios en Corea en Japón y en
otros países La idea es que a estas
familias no les faltara el dinero para
levantar su imperio un imperio que
funcionaría de forma totalmente privada
y Autónoma en el día a día Pero que eso
sí a cambio tendría que cumplir los
objetivos de producción establecidos por
el gobierno
y así es mis queridos amigos de la
comunidad de visualpolitik como se
crearon los famosos chiebols es decir
los grandes conglomerados empresariales
que producían prácticamente de todo
hablamos de gigantes como el grupo
Samsung el grupo Hyundai o otros como el
grupo lote que durante décadas Fueron
tremendamente favorecidos por el estado
y cuando decimos que fabricaban
prácticamente de todo lo decimos muy en
serio Porque es que Samsung fabrica
aires acondicionados smartphones
televisores Microchips frigoríficos por
producir produce hasta barcos por
ejemplo para que os hagáis una idea de
lo que estamos hablando tan solo el
grupo Samsung todavía representa ojo el
20% del pib surcoreano ya sé lo que
estáis pensando es una auténtica locura
otro buen ejemplo es el grupo Bosco que
fue el chebol que más dinero recibió de
la reparaciones japonesas Ni más ni
menos que 100 de los 800 millones de
dólares pagados por Tokio terminaron en
esta compañía con ese dinero pues que
construyó enormes y modernas plantas de
acero lo que junto a los bajos salarios
hizo que fuese terriblemente competitiva
el resultado es que casi 60 años después
Bosco es todavía el sexto mayor
fabricante de acero a nivel mundial
curioso nos parece seguro que alguno
habréis pensado en la unión soviética y
en cierto modo es normal en Corea del
Sur el gobierno tenía planes
quinquenales y fijaba los objetivos de
producción sin embargo la gran
diferencia es que en Corea nunca
tuvieron intención de que los medios de
producción fueran estatales de hecho el
sector privado y sobre todo estos
tuvieron manga bastante ancha
tiene una primera etapa a las
inversiones se dirigieron a industrias
relativamente simples y fáciles de
establecer Sin embargo a medida que
éstas comenzaban a producir el estado
financiaba el desarrollo de producciones
cada vez más y más complejas y así del
acero se pasó a los coches y a los
barcos y de estos a la electrónica y así
sucesivamente ir a la construcción de
una inmensa cadena de producción Made In
Korea pero aquí no termina la cosa al
mismo tiempo el gobierno también apoyó
la apertura al comercio exterior Eso sí
de forma fundamentalmente unidireccional
Es decir de Corea para el mundo pero no
al revés la idea era convertirse en una
megafábrica para el resto del planeta al
tiempo que se obligaba a los surcoreanos
a consumir sus productos en el mercado
nacional en la práctica el gobierno solo
daba vía libre para comprar en el
extranjero aquellos productos que
necesitara la propia industria nacional
nada más Pero quizás lo más llamativo es
que para lograr impulsar las
exportaciones el estado hizo
prácticamente de todo no solo daba
financiación barata sino que también
daba un montón de ayudas Fiscales y
regulatorias por ejemplo las empresas
que exportaban tenían todo tipo de
beneficios reducciones en el impuesto
sobre beneficios exerciones de aranceles
prestamos en divisa extranjera y hasta
un seguro de exportación costeado por el
mismísimo estado y no solo eso que
necesitaban construir una fábrica nueva
o una carretera no había problema el
estado se ocupaba de las expresiones y
de todo lo que hiciera falta barra libre
a cambio de invertir producir y exportar
estos privilegios los podemos ver
perfectamente si echamos un vistazo a
los tipos de interés subvencionados en
1965 por ejemplo mientras que los
préstamos se daban a tipos del 26% los
préstamos a las empresas de exportación
Tenían un coste de apenas un seis y
medio por ciento estos préstamos eran
conocidos Como préstamos políticos y
fundamentalmente eran otorgados por el
Banco Industrial de Corea y por el banco
de desarrollo de Corea dos entidades
financieras de propiedad Estatal de
hecho los chevrolets llegaron a recibir
incluso préstamos con interés negativo
es decir que los bancos públicos les
pagaban por prestarles dinero
pero esperad un momento porque todavía
no hemos terminado el gobierno de Park
también despreciaba en la medida de lo
posible el one que es la divisa nacional
para que fuera más barato comprar desde
el extranjero Y sí ya sé lo que estáis
pensando pero qué barbaridad si todo el
mundo sabe sobre todo si ve visual
economic que eso destruye riqueza y es
verdad pero también tiene otro efecto
que en ese momento era totalmente
prioritario para la dictadura ayudaba a
exportar más barato en cierta formaba
como una transferencia del bolsillo de
los su rcoreanos a los grandes grupos
exportadores del país Por así decirlo se
mermaba el poder adquisitivo de los
surcoreanos a cambio de enriquecer a los
grandes conglomerados Claro que ese no
fue el único sacrificio
los trabajadores surcoreanos también
tuvieron que lidiar con incrementos de
salarios que estaban muy por debajo de
los incrementos de productividad Y
diréis por qué pues para evitar a toda
Costa que los costes se disparasen esto
explica Por qué los se hicieron cada vez
más importantes dentro de la economía
nacional lo tenían todo a su favor Y sí
imagino lo que estaréis pensando menudo
sistema más Injusto Pues sí tenéis razón
pero al menos consiguieron una cosa
redujeron muchísimo la pobreza la gente
dejó de trabajar en el campo y pasó a
trabajar en fábricas que aunque pagaban
mal les hacían ganar más dinero que
plantando patatas de esta forma si en el
año 65 más del 40% de la población era
considerada Pobre de solemnidad este
porcentaje se redujo hasta el 9,8% en el
año 81 Por supuesto todo esto promovió
un enorme Éxodo de población del campo a
la ciudad en las zonas Rurales las tasas
de pobreza eran muchísimo más altas Pues
bien aquí nos encontramos con otro de
los grandes iconos del despegue de Corea
el saimaul un don que traducido al
español significaría algo así como
movimiento nueva aldea
fue una iniciativa lanzada por Park en
el año 1970 con el objetivo de
modernizar la Corea rural que por
supuesto seguía siendo terriblemente
pobre en este caso en lugar de darles
dinero O decidir desde el gobierno
central que tenían o no que hacer para
salir adelante lo que hizo el Gobierno
fue entregarle es una cantidad fija
irregular de materiales de construcción
entonces las comunidades rurales
decidían Qué hacer con ellos y a las que
mejor aprovechasen los recursos en las
premiaban con más materiales extra
y Grace funciona esta política Pues el
éxito fue tal que todavía a día de hoy
53 años después de su creación este
movimiento sigue en cierto modo
existiendo y de hecho Corea del Sur lo
intenta exportar como modelo a países
pobres Con la difusión de ese maule un
don estamos ayudando a las naciones en
desarrollo a confiar en la prosperidad
al compartir nuestra experiencia de
desarrollo económico básicamente la idea
era la siguiente no les des peces dales
cañas de pescar pero anécdotas aparte
como ocurre con todas las dictaduras ni
todo es tan bonito como parece ni duran
para siempre el presidente parks fue
asesinado habéis oído bien asesinado el
26 de octubre de 1979 por el director de
la kci a que era el servicio secreto
surcoreano durante una cena privada
claro que el país continuó bajo las
riendas de una dictadura militar hasta
principios de los años 90 sí habéis oído
bien la democracia surcoreana es mucho
más joven de lo que os podéis imaginar
El caso es que lo que respecta a la
economía las décadas de los 80 y los 90
sí que trajeron consigo muchos cambios
entre otras cosas porque el modelo de
Park también Tuvo muchos problemas la
Competencia brillaba por su ausencia las
empresas eran terriblemente dependientes
de los bajos costes laborales los tipos
de cambio de preciados y las ayudas del
gobierno Así que muchas inversiones no
eran del todo productivas y la falta de
innovación era un problema digamos que
las empresas surcoreanas sabían copiar
muy bien Pero tenían muchísimos más
problemas para crear cosas nuevas y ojo
porque esto no es todo las condiciones
de vida en el país eran peores de lo que
correspondía para su nivel de desarrollo
económico en general escapar de la
pobreza es mucho más fácil que escapar
de la llamada trampa de los ingresos
medios de hecho es muy posible que Corea
del Sur fuese hoy mucho más rica de no
haber aplicado tan a rajatabla el modelo
instalado por parto sin ir más lejos en
la comparación con los otros tigres
asiáticos no creáis que sale También
parada y exactamente por este motivo los
gobiernos posteriores a Park y
especialmente los gobiernos democráticos
han hecho
plataformas para acabar con los y abrir
el país de una vez por todas a la
competencia y a la inversión extranjera
en masa y sabéis que esto ha funcionado
aún mejor de hecho fijaos en este otro
gráfico
lo que estáis viendo ahora es la
inversión extranjera directa en Corea
del Sur respecto al producto interior
bruto como veis a medida que el país
abandonó el proteccionismo los capitales
extranjeros comenzaron a llegar como si
no hubiera mañana y con la apertura las
empresas surcoreanas también tuvieron
que apostar mucho más por la innovación
de hecho sin la creciente apertura de
los años 80 y 90 es muy probable que la
industria surcoreana se hubiera quedado
muy atrás si algo está claro es que pese
a todo este proceso de industrialización
fue un éxito tremendo pasar de una
economía agraria una economía Industrial
siempre supone un gran salto adelante y
ojo porque esto también ocurrió en los
Unión soviética a diferencia es que en
Corea apostaron porque la iniciativa la
tuvieran las empresas privadas y no el
estado y Esto fue decisivo pero como
veis tampoco arregló todos los problemas
y llegados hasta aquí como lo prometido
es deuda recomendaros un canal que nos
ha encantado Planet Wild es un proyecto
único porque nos enseña Cómo podemos
proteger el medio ambiente con unos
vídeos Sencillamente espectaculares y
además muy educativos Planet Wild es una
comunidad global de personas que quieren
mejorar el mundo financiando proyectos
trascendentes de protección
medioambiental pero es que además tú
también puedes unirte si crees que es el
momento de actuar y proteger el planeta
nosotros ya formamos parte de esta
comunidad porque nos parece una forma
Revolucionaria de generar un impacto
positivo visible en nuestro entorno sus
vídeos os van a encantar porque aprendes
al mismo tiempo que te lo pasas bien hay
además dos vídeos que me han gustado
especialmente y me gustaría recomendaros
uno sobre el mochuelo europeo que es una
pequeña ave rapaz que siempre he
encontrado como muy adorable muy Cookie
y que por desgracia se encuentra en
peligro de extinción y otro que también
os recomiendo es en el que hablan de
cómo se está restaurando el ecosistema
de un río tras la repentina muerte de
millones de peces en un desastre
ecológico podéis echarles un vistazo en
la descripción o en las tarjetas que
hemos puesto ahora un saludo y hasta la
próxima